welcome to this video playing else econ
since they are also some guy called etsy
com hmm strange do we get the no no
damage again or no names Oh again oops
the Queens gambit declined exchange
let's see what line is playing just the
the classic a-line these six young ok
let's go for long castles I have really
bad experience with castling long in the
exchange but let's try that again again
the day 94 I forgot about 94 it didn't
do it ok that if I was interesting
because a to wangs ok he's immediately
going for it so should I play g55 no
it's got night age 5 not good probably
tricky to play and I'm trying to be
ready for c 5 and 20 Bishop we fight the
Fiat exit in a way like 97 or so I calf
g5 or at night 67 I got dropped back to
g3 okay should I just take take f6 where
I cannot go g5 quickly maybe I need some
more firepower here
a five maybe wants to a for I don't know
okay I'm I want to want to get get ahead
here it's clear that he's got
counterplay no doubt about that before I
a 45 all kinds of moves let's see
yeah he's got the night on a fade and
yeah according to Ben Lawson you never
again going to get meet it with a night
on on a fade there's a grain of truth um
in there so let's see how to how to do
that
I'll get the night reform maybe and
Queen d2 at least I don't have a
structural problem I mean and my
position is still fairly healthy I don't
see how to really get something on the
king though I can't play Knight f4 and
stuff but yeah now i can get to get a
night to deform not that it's
necessarily so useful I can't kill maybe
f3 King edge to aquino aquino h2 King
edge to Queen h2s still no no threat
really maybe at the right moment to
capture him
yeah if he's retreating the rook yeah he
might detect the form i mean i will have
i will i would have threats if i can
actually triple on the edge far like
rook age 40 page 1 queen age too but
this looks like too much to ask for i
can try them you can try that yeah now i
have c to protected but if it is it is
it enough i mean it looks dangerous
yeah i'm going to try this tripling
business okay but then he will make me
on c1 hmm that's not good I think I
should I should retreat here really
can't see one that's a scary square
yes John
what can I do something really drastic
here like f 5 94 f 6 or something it
looks it looks like a bit much but maybe
probably this is not on at least he
basically never can take on d4 unless
it's a mate really a direct mate
other than that he's made it himself
John very very tough position
wait there's no meat on c1 anymore you
catch it look H it now maybe yeah that's
at least potential come on
Wow
time warning check check check
check grah Alfred white forfeits on time
yeah just great with one second yeah
yeah talk about being unlucky can it's
very difficult to play of course why
this just winning no problem I just need
to have some time on the clock here here
it's it's just winning but um yes this
is the easiest check and that's it ah
yeah and at the end term it's of course
just the draw at least it this is just a
big mistake I mean cool Queen d7 just
it's just giving the game away basically
check so here maybe they are better
moves Queen g three wins okay yeah but
it's difficult I only have 20 seconds on
the clock so on i was i was actually
forgetting that i can take with this
check if I of course this was a decision
that you can just add you just need to
move with so little time and he's got
Roxy 7 that this is the only defense
until here again this is just winning I
don't have I just I just didn't have the
the nerve to play the right moves with
no time so it's tricky and yeah and at
the end term it's probably
this is probably a draw okay here rupee
ages even mating okay I should look at
this anymore doesn't make make much
sense thanks for watching